- Please welcome comedy
legend, beautiful woman,
and my dear friend, Molly Shannon.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
By the way, you look so beautiful.
- So do you.
Hi, you guys.
This is so fun.
You look so pretty, Drew.
- Oh, Molly, I--
- Wait do I stand here?
I'm so nervous.
- I love you so much.
Why don't you come take a seat over here?
They say it's the better lighting.
So I'd rather you have that.
- Okay, good, good.
- Molly and I, we made really
close friends on the movie
and we continued that friendship,
and I was always able to talk
to you about life and family
and friendship and the real stuff
that's important between girlfriends.
- Yes, Drew, that's so sweet.
And women need other
women, and it's so nice.
And you know, I feel
the same way about you.
- We had a great time making that movie.
- And you were a real
role model for me on set.
I really learned how to
behave in show business
from Drew Barrymore.
(audience applauding)
Yeah, you taught me.
- Well, that makes me happy
because you were also my Velcro
when I would go to Saturday Night Live,
which was my most important institution.
I first hosted in 1982 at seven years old.
I'm still the youngest host.
- Oh my god.
That's crazy.
- I'm like seriously going to be so happy
and slightly resent any child that takes
that title away from me.
I'll be like, "I'm so happy for you."
(audience laughing)
And of course, my favorite
segment on the show was
(clapping)
- [Both] Dog show!
(laughing)
- And Drew was so funny.
I actually put it on my Instagram
because it is my favorite dog show.
She played Michael Trulio.
It's one of my favorite performances.
You embraced Michael Trulio.
- Now, I wanna wuickly talk to you
about the show of the year, "White Lotus."
(audience cheering)
- I wanted to do a really good job
'cause I knew it was a really good part.
We shot it in Maui.
We all lived at The Four Seasons.
It was a dream job.
I got to bring my kids cause
they were in remote school,
and they would, I would, I'd be like,
"I'm going to shoot a scene in the lobby."
And they would like to snorkel
and then walk back with
their gear on and be like,
"Hi, Molly. Hi, Mike."
And it was the greatest job for a mom.
- Now you have another show on HBO Max,
and you are a talk show
host in this amazing series
that is going into season two.
It's wildly popular.
It's called "The Other Two."
It's on HBO Max.
Take a look.
- Do you have a sad, grumpy
friend who needs a pick-me-up?
Then enter them to win a
shopping spree with me, Pat,
sponsored by MasterCard, but
paid for by me personally.
- Great. Number 13.
- [Producer] Hold for camera reset.
- Hey, Brookie, we're really
scheduling a lot of these,
but don't forget
that I have Lisa son's
wedding in Ohio next month.
- Keep reading.
- Do you like weddings?
Win a chance to come to my
friend, Lisa son's wedding
in Ohio next month.
Oh. With me, Pat.
(audience cheering)
- How do you feel
playing a talk show host?
- I love playing a talk show host.
It's so fun.
So I'm pretending to do
what you do in real life.
And I have to say, I love it.
(upbeat music)